alright i'm in the heart of ant city  yonge and sheppard trong and i'm here  outside Toronto dance salsa the studio  there is across the way and we're doing  a special Zuma for charity event and so  I haven't done Zuma in a long long time  and I'm excited see how it goes let's  see some Zumba you don't have a Zumba no  I think you can zoom bar no okay  hi everyone it's jessica from tirana  dance salsa and we are about to start  our Zumba for her charity events one  hundred percent of the proceeds are  going to the heart and stroke foundation  we at TDS embody family we love to give  back to our community and this is such a  really just a fun way to get sweaty have  fun dance it out to music and give back  to a charity so we're promoting healthy  hearts and smile then super fun so  comments zumba zumba zumba with turning  salsa  the class for the concern is just  starting up yeah so I'm gonna try to see  what  you